hi reject nation I'm Greg Alba how are
you doing Ashley I'm so good and I'm so
happy that you're wearing this shirt
that I got you Ashley got me this shirt
for my birthday and I figured I should
probably wear it around her I wear this
shirt at least once a week but every
time I see you I just don't happen to be
wearing this shirt I'm like no words no
it's true
ask these guys I usually wear this shirt
I believe all right thanks I like it
which friend do you think you are
Phoebe really more like Rachel I think
I'm a little bit of all of them my
competitiveness is like Monica kind of
like Rachel I think that my like
flightiness is a little like Phoebe I'm
yeah I'm a little bit like all the guys
Tom as hot as Joey his funniest anyway
we're gonna watch this video patron
request here one of our top reward tiers
are video requests moon was definitely
doing put up on the youtubes and we're
gonna do top 10 upcoming movies that
might suck in 2019 I can think of a few
- why would I subscribe before watching
the video that's true just they didn't
think same I stuck in the Charlie's
Angels oh the ring
you knew that your girl yes Lizabeth
banks is directing it what I miss all
this news really hey Joe I have a this
will be fine at the same time there's
also Logan and a bunch of other good
movies are they are younger yeah I got
got a lot of educating to do
[Laughter]
I know
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I think that'll do good revitalising do
not know about any of you Carrie's gonna
be
[Music]
number five I have faith in this movie
names in the trailer with proper but
he's not drinking this one we should
watch it I like the big eyes now it's
February
well how many movies are there they
always make money doesn't matter have
lives lost
[Music]
based on the box office returns there's
obviously an audience out there for
these movies anything we can count on a
new entry every year or so that being
said there's little doubt that I'm the
do family funeral will have a longtime
fans laughing all the way to the
graveyard others meanwhile are likely
keeping their fingers crossed that this
is the final nail in the coffin making
her really I've been waiting for this
have you been and it's the first one did
you strap I saw some of it I was like
not super feeling I'm surprised I think
it's gonna flop like straight-to-video
or like I loved their voices
winters ugly dolls ugly don't even heard
of some future like commercials deliver
exactly what we expected for the first
time in my life here we can only hope
ugly dolls won't follow the latter I
feel you can make a movie out of it or
depending how they turn out
dishonorable mentions okay
I have a lot of faith in Terminator 6
Hellboy did not make the list I want you
to keep them on so much better without
well ok let's start off with the first
one I did know that they were doing a
reboot on this you know the kid who's
like super popular right now Noah sent
in he's playing one of the girls love
interest in this gosh I think based on
the cast especially with that kid
because he's like super popular right
now yeah I think it's gonna do really
well with like a younger audience yeah
cuz he's in all those like teen Netflix
movies right now so I feel like it's
gonna bring that I mean he's a he's a
charming guy do you see that the two all
the boys I love yeah he's a charming guy
yeah he's he's adorable
yeah he's very adorable I mean Kristen
Stewart you love her I like that like
that was your celebrity crush when we
were younger you I never loved I was
gladly admitted if I felt that way would
ever have a celebrity crush on persons 1
when did this ever occur in my life I
would not be ashamed to a minute I'll
still sell me don't you don't like her I
don't mind her I feel like in the big
movies like this I feel like when she
does indie films she really cares and
she does a great job but she does
big-budget films she is clearly catch
cash cash cash Inge caching
not catching a page a cashing a paycheck
way they got to Bosley's Djimon Honsou
and Patrick Stewart what is this movie
it's kind of cool that it's directed by
Emily Banks though Elizabeth that's
right Wow I feel like Elizabeth Banks I
wish she did a good job with a
pitch-perfect sequel that she handled I
think she is very talented this could be
cool I guess he's gonna be fine I like
the Charlie's Angels premise is silly
you know but I just think that if we're
gonna be taking male-driven movies and
rebooting them with females I think you
should have made Charlie's Angels all
men oh yeah that would have worked
better yeah all the women watching to
hear this yeah that could have been cool
actually you know they're like always
flip-flopping it so it actually could
have been funny there's no a kid and you
know Charlie's Devils yeah oh god why
isn't Hollywood talking to me I got all
the ideas I think it's gonna be like
very fun movie but like obviously like
their other first movie was like very
unrealistic but fun x-men Dark Phoenix
Ashley doesn't know jack about x-men I'm
so bad with all the x-men movies I
really don't know but I did love Logan I
did a trailer review for this it's kind
of a long one with John and Andrews so
if you want to know my opinion on it
long story short I have faith in it when
it seems like no one else does but you
go watch that whole review haha
promoting another video shaft this one
sounds terrible I think my my
that is that of all these movies this
one will do the worst and it like
box-office wise or a critic wise all of
it i specially box-office wise i just
feel like it it just seems like a
terrible idea
I did see like one of the original shaft
films when I was much younger remember
barely remember the Sam Jackson one but
this is just a ridiculous concept cuz
you got oh gee shaft who's still alive
good for him and you got Sam Jackson
shaft who apparently was the nephew of
chef and then you have this other chef
the two to carry on the shaft of French
who's shifting the shaft we have a movie
news show but then again chef was never
really a serious franchise maybe if they
play on the silliness of it I think they
make fun of themselves with it then you
know what I mean like then maybe it'll
be better knowing my luck with how I
predict things I'll probably end up
being the best one on his whole list
right okay The Grudge what are they they
like soft rebooting it where it's not
exactly a sequel and not exactly a
remake like it's just another install
because I remember like one in two were
linked but I never saw three and that
kind of just looked like a video yeah I
think that one was just like yeah I
think that the villains are back but
none of the protagonists early it sounds
like that's kind of what they're doing
here you know bringing back the villainy
characters there's just something about
seeing the girl crawling it freaks me
out I'll see it I'm sure cuz I pretty
much I didn't see the last one though I
didn't even know that it came out no one
did
okay I did see the first in second or
not the first one was way better than
the second one
I'll go see it I'm sure it's a horror
movie I'm sure I'll see it but maybe
it'll be really cool care everyone's
past I feel like you gotta be something
completely different I think it's not
the Hedgehog movie would be a great idea
I've been saying that if you're gonna do
video game adaptations make them animate
it I was thinking that they should redo
the crash
what's-his-name crash manicure that I
think would be super cool if you make
them animated movies I feel like that
would work really well I think that
Sonic the Hedgehog is actually gonna be
very fun good movie Jim Carrey's yeah
it's playing dr. Robotnik big Sonic
character if it's animated you could get
wildly inventive with it like they
reference the lego movie at one point
for a different movie but the lego movie
is insanely animated with its animation
I feel like with Sonic like when he's
going all Sonic the Hedgehog you hit
like that would be so awesome is he in
an animated film yes I'm so glad that
they didn't do live-action yeah that'd
be terrible yeah but I think this is
gonna do really well cuz I think that
kids will see it who don't really know
what Sonic the Hedgehog is and I think
it's gonna reboot it and they'll be like
toys and this and that the like kid's
gonna like but then also people like our
age
Madea yeah she exists that's some guy I
haven't even seen him a day a movie
there's something appealing about it
obviously to have people keep coming
back for more
it's gotta be funny or entertaining I
don't know what it's gonna be but I feel
like if you're a fan of Madea you must
just like love that character so much
that no matter how terrible the movies
are just fun to see that person over and
over again cuz at this point my dad is
kind of just like a long-running TV show
with the amount of movies that come out
I think Angry Birds too is gonna flop
Angry Birds - yeah the first one I
wasn't really in love with and I love
animated movies I know you do -
favorites but - together and I tried
watching it I think it came on like
Netflix at one point or something you
couldn't get into it like the whole
reason I think it performed well at the
box office is because Angry Birds is hot
at the time but the fact that it wasn't
loved by any I don't know anyone who
loves that movie because it made a lot
of money but I think they're really
gonna see the repercussions of not
having a good first movie like Legos
I've always been you know a popular toy
brand whatever but the lego movie
everyone thought that was gonna be
terrible like this sounds stupid a lego
movie and then it ends up being great
they have a franchise you know that's
good but Angry Birds are like no one
liked it Angry Birds not hot anymore so
why would it do well the ugly dolls I
can't comment on
anything about them I think you can
adapt anything and possibly make it good
the lego movie proved you can do that
Dora the accessible Dora the Explorer as
a live-action movie I think that's gonna
do really well I think that sounds like
a cool con I think financially it'll do
well I don't know how well again I don't
know how it can lend itself to a
live-action/animated I think they're
gonna yeah probably if I gonna be mocap
or something I don't know how you could
turn it into a story though like it come
like not a compelling story but it a but
one that you can get on a true adventure
with and be like this was really but
then again so have you watched Dorothy's
floor
she always has like like a specific
thing to do that day she's got a map and
she's got to get somewhere so already
with that set up you know she's gonna
have her she's gonna have some sort of
thing that she's got to get to by the
end of the movie and there's gonna be
lots that come in her way and she has
her map and you should write right for
them this was a movie fight you have
proven me wrong you've persuaded Matt
you have persuade and then there's
always like some sort of obstacle that
comes in her way and she has to figure
out her way around it like she's about
to go through something but then like a
bridge falls and she gotta figure it out
there's gonna be and it's gonna be an
action adventure and I'm excited oh I
think you can make the obstacles be
representative of her parents who
clearly do not take care of her they
just let her run - you don't even know
where she like the ops as she overcomes
physical obstacles she will also
overcome emotional right this I so I say
we should write one for Diego her cousin
who works with animals there you go in
the gritty live action what's the top
one that you will go see first out of
all I don't know elite is the first one
I would see then Charlie's Angels last
one ugly ugly dolls I have no interest
in like even checking out a trailer for
that that sounds like super boring maybe
it's gonna be super cool and prove us
both ground let's find out 2019
hopefully this channel still around and
maybe Ashley still
Oh Mike come on guys subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell what film do you think will suck
and Ashley go check around on Instagram
yeah I don't have an Instagram account
right now you don't
I haven't had I haven't been a social
media for like a week and a half how
does it feel terrible Oh terribly I miss
all the DMS from all the gay guys posted
recently no no no John has access to it
you know promote stuff shake us off
patreon we got stuff oh crap I almost
forgot make sure the day shout out to
David Waterhouse David lately we've been
talking a lot about how you know with
mental health conditions that we both
can often go through you have had to
overcome so much in your life and I want
you to know buddy I want to put this out
there your one major inspiration in my
life and I'm so happy to know you and in
fact that you pledged to our patreon and
one of our top pledges is crazy to me
considering how much you give to us
beyond that in terms of life lessons and
understanding so thanks for being such a
kind-hearted gentleman and hopefully you
have a good holidays and say how to
Rosie Leigh for me my friend